unter den letzten video gab es
beschwerden darüber dass ich schon
lieber mit dem thema aliens beschäftigt
habe aber außerirdische will man ein
zentraler forschungszweig der
wissenschaft und es wird an allen ecken
und enden nach ihnen gesucht und
vielleicht stehen da unsere chancen
einfach schlecht weil wir einsam sind
weil sich unsere milchstraße in einem
besonders lehrern teil des universums
befindet diensten sprechen nämlich
dafür dass sich unsere galaxie in den
größten bekannten beugt des universums
befindet einen besonders leeren bereich
des weltalls wenn wir also einfach
einsam im weltraum liegt zurzeit häufig
schwer zu bekommen
zugegeben bei ihnen thema spielen aliens
erstmal nur eine geringe rolle aber die
nasa die applikationen usw
wie alle suchen intensiv nach
außerirdischen egal ob marcelos
exoplaneten radiosignale überall wird
nach ihm gesucht werden milliarden in
die forschung gesteckt und da ist es
kein wunder dass es hier immer wieder
auf wachstum um außerirdische das wird
auch so bleiben weil es einfach eines
der ganz großen themen der forschung
ist die menschheit ist unglaublich
neugierig daraus eine der wichtigsten
fragen zu erforschen
seit wir im wahrsten sinne des wortes
denken können sind wir allein im
universum und jetzt gibt es eine
forschungsarbeit die indizien dafür
gesammelt hat dass wir zumindest in
einem sehr sehr leeren bereich des
weltalls sind was natürlich die chancen
auf den ersten kontakt schmälern
könnte aber der reihe nach
das universum ist eigentlich ein ort in
dem die materie gleichmäßig über den
raum verteilt ist das einzig
ungleichmäßige dass wir hier von der
erde aussehen dass uns unsere
milchstraße unsere galaxie wie ich als
helles band über den himmel ziehen aber
das ist mehr eine frage des standen sich
ist die materie regelmäßig versagt
doch es gibt strukturen im weltall die
materie dann doch etwas sortieren und
mit wenigen ländern aus gars
galaxienhaufen und sehr leeren bereichen
den sogenannten beugt das universum
sortieren in den letzten jahren gab es
immer wieder studien die untersucht
haben wo unsere galaxie die milchstraße
eigentlich liegt da wo es richtig eng
wird oder er in einem sehr leeren
bereich in einem wort sie kamen zu dem
ergebnis dass wir eher in einem sehr
leeren bereich des weltalls wiegen wenn
hochscheidt und seine kolleginnen und
kollegen von der university of wisconsin
madison usa werteten jetzt spektrograph
ische daten von objekten in unserer
näheren umgebung und von entfernten
objekten aus und kamen zu einem
spektakulären ergebnis zitat das von
uns ermittelte dichten profil passt zu
den kosmologischen beobachtungen es
spricht dafür dass die milchstraße in
einer großen leere liegt das sagt die
forscherin mitbürger und das absolut
beeindruckende die milchstraße liegt
demnach im größten bisher bekannten
voltaire ist sieben mal größer als
üblicherweise will das würde auch ein
weiteres rätsel der astrophysik lösen
die hubble konstante der wert für die
kosmische expansionsrate der ist je
nachdem ob er anhand der kosmischen
hintergrundstrahlung oder anhand von
galaxien und supernovae berechnet wird
unterschiedlich zitat eigentlich müsste
man die gleichen werte für die
kosmische expansion frage bekommen egal
welche methode man nutzt aber wenn wir
wirklich in einem wald leben dann
könnte dies die diskrepanzen erklären
sagt bahnhof scheitern würden wir
nämlich durch die ungleiche verteilung
der materie in unserer nähe und weit
entfernt dadurch würden einfach
messwerte der rotverschiebung wird mehr
halten wie die ergebnisse für die
messung der habe konstante beeinflusst
aber jetzt muss erstmal weitere studien
geben die die these des wolfs in dem wir
uns befinden bestätigen oder widerlegen
bedingungen auf das letzte video könnte
das ein grund sein warum uns
außerirdische noch nicht besucht haben
es gibt einfach keine in unserer
umgebung aber auch das ist nur ein
entweder ich bin dagegen
wie die nasa überzeugt davon dass wir
schon bald auf außerirdisches
lebensgroßen werden klüpfel milliarden
in die forschung nach gesteckt werden
ist es wenn es sie gibt
dafür spricht eine menge ziemlich
wahrscheinlich dass sich auch
aufgespürt werden so jetzt seid ihr
brand vorbild sein
der wettbewerb für euch in dem es
insgesamt achtung 21.000 euro gewinn
getrickst vater wir unterstützen das
und die chancen dort will sie stehen
echt nicht schlecht gesucht werden die
besten web videos für die wissenschaft
und wenn ihr das ein wenig kreativ
angeht dann habt ihr wirklich ziemlich
große chance und einfach achtung hier
draufklicken da gibt es alle infos und
damit auch genug zeit zum klicken
haushalt ich das video jetzt machen
bis dann bleibt dran